attack as soon as you swing that's when
he back dash is electric you know so
yeah yeah
many times too yeah
jackson five though going back to the
namesake of the jackman
look at this dude we're basic where
where
this is basically uh infinite the shirt
just where we found the walls
i love this dude just like my face
yeah one of my favorite wall stages in
this game i jack the five with the jack
like you said sapito with the lay i
think sapito is pretty much only lay as
it says in his online name sapito lay
yeah this lace looks good man really
good yeah
[Music]
wow wow red the
throw attempt there got the launch too
big boy combo
defense on the second low that that's
the string
yeah that string has no mix if that
happens
slam
oh my god now jackson five with the huge
lead just the poke something out heavy
oh immediately into the 1-15 time
wow
the wall not there
oh i can't believe you would
immediately challenge the immediately
challenged with the ball 74.
nice job there for jackson five ooh down
four two gets blocked but no punish from
sapito
wow that's the second hit rock saves
himself from getting launched ah string
just finishes it out
i love the mid-range tools that both
these guys are using right now that down
forward four at the perfect spacing 50
50 again
close to the safe mid clock come back
got the back
that i gotta turn around deep
windmill punches looking for the last
high just in case
oh dear lord oh dear lord
oh
nice
jackson 5 with the downford one perfect
perfect place to put that there too
the jackson 5 is so good at finding
these forward two sidestep twos right
now and even the debugger
challenges immediately after the move
oh
nice size that possibly punished he
stepped into the lost 94 dude like the
same kind of direction oh the fourth one
caught him trying to step no
way that he bounced off from the wall
from one hit before double panicking
slam oh
i like the layers i like the layers yeah
jack
jack right there with the full couch
down for two he could do
mid after the second hit or high or low
so he decided to go for the mid into low
and then the double layers is if they
stayed grounded the low is still
grounded there and if they got up to
defend they have to guess that it's
gonna be mid low version so good choice
there good choice to jackson five yeah i
mean jack's five also you know he did
see he did see some of some little uh
weaknesses there right the throw
breaking game wasn't the best from
sapito so you know i think he's he's
that's the reason why he's been throwing
out those throws you know even though
they did get launched that first round
he doesn't care because he needs you
know i think as a jack player you need
to throw you know you need to know how
to throw and jack does have a real throw
game so yeah uh and you know jack's five
long long time jack player so he knows
exactly how to play the character very
well uh and i mean he just looks so good
too sapito you know he just had the he
had some mix-ups you know some
opportunities but at the end there just
just got beat
i think uh the last match we saw of
sapito was utilizing the snake sense a
lot and that's something that he's not
going to be able to use as freely
against jack especially these big body
characters where their arms are more
forward and their legs are farther back
because snake 4-1 in that sense uh even
if the four could hit the four is really
hard to hit because their legs are
further retracted and also if before
does hit a lot of times the one could
whip even if the four hit because would
that make it like punishable
i believe so yeah i believe so
could be nasty
all right here we go though going into
the last day on earth again
i don't know where these zombies are
coming from but they hear
round one
fight
razor rush mid zapito first round fight
it feels like when sapito gets his
offense going he does a really really
good job but
jackson five is also someone that
challenges a lot he will challenge on
your offense so
i like both these players uh challenges
a lot like uh jackson five of the
neutral a lot of forward two a lot of
sidestep two really working out for him
so pizzo too sometimes when you're
getting pressured the one one they've
been up and out a lot four four three
gets whipped punished there all right
he's also been getting a lot of sidestep
fours as well too so he's definitely he
has his movement into launchers
available but
so scary
so patience
oh my gosh
going under the two jab with the high
crush well played by sapido great choice
yeah very good
wow
straight straight-up walk-up wall
standing one
he made him think about it with just
that one low beforehand
oh i love the way he's stepping with him
jackson five keeping his back against
the wall but sapido against the play
dead launcher yeah that played that's
such a good move too to make people
whiff
it's kind of like an aop of his own
right jackhammer whip going back in with
the razor rush keeping up the pressure
but jackson five not afraid to start
swinging back i love the challenges with
the down back one from a lot of these
animal transitions
it's really forcing uh sabino to like
throw away his animal stance offense to
go for the low parry or the low block
yeah very very good and also the thing
i'm like about jack's five right now is
that he is throwing these strings out
but spito catch him with four four three
gonna get it to the other wall just yes
sure and the angle grayson is good not
gonna get the grounded hit to set up the
okie properly
that was counterintuitive
dude his fingernails oh my god
jackson 5.
jesus what a comeback
oh nice punishment but the all four
three big counter
opportunities i i think you might be
right yeah i think it might have been
could the throw cost and that time all
the bad turns turn
new thing in tekken 7 throws are counter
hittable now
timing call out and jackson five had the
right move choice but not the right
timing so pedal answers back yeah i mean
that's one thing too we said that the
jackson five he was getting a lot of
mileage off these throws with that throw
cost in that last round there because of
that counter hit state unfortunate but
that's how it goes sometimes and so
people looking real good
now that i think about tekken 7's throw
system i'm like
ah you could counter it throws they
should elevate them just normal pranks
man
that hurts so much so that's a great
answer from sabito there like he he saw
that you know that's a very common thing
that jack dude does right uh instead of
going for the 2-1 punish even though
something might be too unpunishable it
does more damage but just doing the
single two jab gives jack more frame
advantage so a lot of times you'll see
jack players off to go for just a single
two jab a lot of times the single two
the jackhammer for a big mid or the
throw game starts opening up after the
single two jab but sapido had it scouted
with that up four three
yeah and that was like clean up four
three two got the counter head got the
launch got everything else sapito making
that comeback there so it was close say
here between jacksonville and sabito uh
i i i guess we'll probably still see the
same characters i've been wrong before
i've been wrong pretty much all the time
so we'll see how his negan sticks
i'm already like yeah if you are you're
already calling it out there it's going
to be
honestly not i think it's really good
i really like the checks he does like
during the animal stance but who knows
yeah yeah
the down back ones and the down forward
ones whenever lay goes into an animal
stance and wants to transition to a
second one those are great checks there
by jackson five
yeah jackson five man he's been playing
so well here but cepito you know making
these comebacks
really enjoying seeing his leg
hey this this place is still on fire
where are the fire
they're firemen they're enjoying the
imaginary fights
with his head propped up like are you
done yet i'm gonna launch you oh
that cost them there too nice launch
just apito gonna get the lead
look at the damage oh
nice punish wow four four two one
didn't have the wall
oh my god he had the one one or the one
two that was counter
a lot of a lot of
crazy that's happening crazy i know yeah
i don't want to call them mistakes
because i don't think any of those were
mistakes those are just odd situations
oh going for the low crush but it's a
slower move leads them back to the gym
oh setting up the animal stances here we
go no it's not that bad
psych
nice
good step yes
real good at stepping in that direction
getting that launch too now look at this
two rounds up on jackson five about to
eliminate jackson five from the
tournament
yeah using that down four two into snake
stance transition got the grounded hit
this time so it worked out
oh
the counter that's not good that's a lot
of damage that's a lot of damage oh
you're going for the big boy cobble too
all the hits of the razor rush look at
his life
this never does that
[Music]
oh my god jackson 5 is throwing out some
heavy moves and the throw gets ducked
once again
that's the thing man
if you rely on the throws too much
because you think it's like a weakness
that you can exploit against an opponent